okay this is episode six open jumper
Fisk yes um honestly it seems like a
slower episode of me but you gotta have
those they pop up they're pretty much
running away from the cops and the SWAT
team when we find out are also on
payroll and they're locked in the
building he convinces the Russian and
they pretty much I didn't kill the
brother I think your batteries just like
you know a fucking you like your fist is
on fire bad but well he did say suck my
dick yes so that means so pretty much
there they're stuck in this building and
it's pretty much a hostage negotiation
because there's a good cop there a
transit to a dead cop okay sorry but I
didn't like wrong place wrong time
yeah no strange sounds in a warehouse
you just turn around and go to the
doughnuts yeah so and pretty much
daredevil is claimed or he's blamed for
everything
now I agree what's gonna be on the hunt
for like they never were before the only
really cool like you know okay like that
was that was really legitimately cool
was when it was Fisk and their double
finally talk couldn't agree more
that's like the only thing in this
episode that really sticks out for me
yeah like it's don't give me it's not
that it's like well what a bad episode
it's like I get if you have to have this
lower stuff is episode it's like an avid
like Avatar The Last Airbender it's like
all the episodes are good so it's just
ranking from best to good and this one's
just yeah I mean it gets a little dull
um you know so saying myself and maybe
he could have the good found a little
action of him stopping me like maybe
other cops coming in or something like
that
of all the episodes this one really
feels like the whole episode was shot in
the dark
yeah well and it pretty much is I mean
you're in a warehouse with no lights or
anything like that um I did enjoy Claire
giving him instructions how to fix the
wound and basically saying we're gonna
have to cauterize it with a flare it's
gonna hurt like hell
bonus I think I beat me up you want me
to save him I will say this you know
they're talking about you even find you
and they'll kill everyone you care about
the kill blah blah blah it's like what
Claire's ass P grass by now I mean
wouldn't she just be like smoke no
because that was through the Russians
that fist didn't know about I don't know
it seems to know ages Rhea I don't get
it well a I'm not sure the Russians
trusted Fisk all that much and they may
have just referred to his like yeah we
found some girl that may know something
like I don't ever remember them giving
her name out and then they just said we
lost her so I but I mean you could be
right by me for a guy that seems to have
like people everywhere I get the feeling
he would know but I guess you never know
um
but ya know my conversation I always
loved those conversations I mean they
did the Dark Knight it was wonderful
when Batman the Joker finally meet and
talk they did and heat went De Niro and
Pacino finally meet and talk I mean I
love those conversations the maid here
on the main bill and they they've been
billed it but they haven't seen each
other they finally get together they
finally meet and they talk and it's done
cool and it's you know he's gonna use
you and I are very similar which is like
oh my god you really just say they said
that I nearly flipped my shit but the
rest of the conversation saved it yeah
and it works again within that whole
theme this show is about the
juxtaposition between the two characters
because he's completely right he's like
we really are the same it's like they
both think they're saving the city yeah
and Murdoch's doing it you know from the
ground up while obviously Fisk is just
blowing things up but yeah they both
completely believe in the righteousness
of their cause like that's the thing I
don't get out of fist bed he's like oh
yeah I'm gonna tear
personally doing it for money like he
thinks he's doing something like he
thinks he's a claim I think he knows
he's doing terrible things oh he's a
werewolf who knows but he's now on those
guys like you know blades do it for the
money planets of it like it you get the
feeling that he has some sort of grand
vision Wow well here's the thing guy me
we've I've been seeing these plans for a
while I we are even talking about this
with age of all try me we've been seeing
these villas that think like you know no
no it's rude destruction is the only
means that we may rebuild and it's I'd
be lying if I said I would almost prefer
a I just did for the money I mean
nowadays because that seems to be much
more rare oh well we got that in Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles and how fascinating
was as I you know what the way he put it
stupid rich funny line yeah like when
it's all said and done you can't remove
a I can talk about that character
okay but you okay you don't go the Ninja
Turtles to talk about any fucking
characters okay you go away to hear
catchphrases and comedy and sea turtles
eat pizza and check the money that you
think was that compelling oh there's a
lot of people in breaking but that's
Breaking Bad you picked like probably
the best bass hotel actually they do not
have pretty degree interesting um but
yeah there's a it's interesting but I'm
not not to say that's bad I mean that
you know what you can't have a villain
that does bit it just needs to be the
new thing that all these villains are
doing it's all something what is gonna
get him because that's what all the
other people in this universe are doing
it for like his collection is cadre of
minions that's they're all doing it for
the money so now we wanted a at top just
like yeah just doing it for the money I
think with the way they set Murdock up
and everything I think that would have
been kind of dull there's God I mean
this was something I mean like you know
the gonna look a flak movie did like
they got a little bit with the Joker
with Jesse and I just want anarchy and
chaos and stuff yeah do you know waited
way different than do often well no no
no I know I'm saying that there's gotta
be there's gotta be other options out
there because I'm just finally getting
like a little like everything else is
good this is just like yeah okay like I
can't
it's like no little because I can't
think of anything else right now I'm not
gonna be like you know come on guys you
know there's so many other options when
it's like I can't think of that many
else but it's like there's gotta be
something else out there outside of you
know we must destroy level the playing
field in order for a new world to grow
oh it makes sense with his character if
it's well written oh and I know here as
they're making that connection between
Murdock and Vanessa who's also the
artist and he considers himself kind of
an artist and his entire the entire
theme around in his control and I will
say whoever he wants to create when he's
doing it through destroying the one
thing that is kind of we keep talking
about you know things being
rationalizing their motivations stuff is
that I will say in some respects I think
everyone has gone through they watch the
news they see a lot shit going on and I
think people love to you know just go to
the simplest can't we just newcomers say
you know like everybody says just or
something or somebody and they get you
know they just go to this horrible place
where it's like can't we just do this
obviously wrong terrible thing like
everybody goes there like once or twice
and they wake up we know they'd be awful
that we'd be terrible people but I think
because everybody goes there at least
like whatever once in their life even if
it's just for like an emotional second
or something like that people can
identify a little bit more at least know
oh I know where that person is coming
from victims never got out of that
emotional second because a lot of people
don't even you know but yeah and maybe
I'm just being a little tired of man
motivation but like I said I'm not
acting like I know the way out or like
the better motivation it's just the one
thing that's like I wish people could
work like a little harder with that but
that's really nitpicking cuz everything
else is been working so hard on I think
I guess these memory matters like it's a
perfectly written character III think
because maybe if I hadn't seen it like a
million times before it seems to be like
the new thing you know with villains
particularly comic book villains um but
ya know it's not like it doesn't bother
me that much but again I think we're
just getting down to like the nitpicking
like you know in Murdock doesn't seem to
act particularly blind and stuff like
that you know it's a
but you know so from that I mean it's
it's just a slower episode i mean IAM
once in a while it could have been a bit
more interesting there's only so long
you can look at yeah that blue warehouse
or just a hospital it's not my favorite
episode the best thing about it is the
conversation with yeah when that
happened i'm like okay like now i'm
interested again you know even like
waste giving the name of this like
accountant guy or whatever it's like I'm
thinking it's gonna be like a big a name
that I know or something I maybe it's a
name of the comic I don't know but it's
like oh there's this guy you know what's
his name what's his a thing's gonna be a
bull's eye or something you know it's
Wieland the the wormy financier guy
white hair glasses always just seems to
be upset yes the money so that is an
important revelation no but I'm using
way to get to fix cuz he's got nothin on
Fisk but we all know how Leland isn't
exactly you know no no bad but that's I
mean she's gonna talk about it's like an
Easter watching it's like waiting for
some sort of other big like holy shit
Devon but only big one again cuz it's
riding on the heels of the last one I
think is that a lot between physics
being a bull's eye that sniper had a
card
y'okay it would be that I didn't see it
is no one there because I saw it the
first time this time we were watching
during the day and it was so dark but
yes I don't know if that's supposed to
be bull's eye yeah I'm guessing it's
gotta be bull's eye he certainly was a
good sniper he hit like you know four
guys in the room I know I also think he
was any further reporter and then like
you know or whatever I don't think so
because oh you know in the science that
was that was the red herring I think to
make you think they were going to kill
but why else would he be on that guy
because he was calling to the lead
detective he had been bugging him all
night and the lead detective then starts
walking over and that's when he got hit
and remembered the whole point was to
frame Murdock and make him what a cop
killer so why are you hitting a reporter
that as far as Fisk knows
is nothing no no that's why are they
weird oh man why would my sniper even if
he was focusing on him so you're
suggesting because he was calming him
over you got okay he's gonna go to him
and it's like I'll just wait for dad to
come to him okay morbid or maybe he was
just you know like checking his sights
then the opportunity presented I don't
know that is the one thing because I'll
tell you this if that is supposed to be
bullseye and it's implying that he
missed that's gonna be it's not gonna
miss it ya know cuz that's my first
thought I was about to see you know I
missed I never miss know your primary
what are you worried because too many
shots were so well delivered and he hit
the cop like no no he was obviously
trying I mean it's a red herring but in
terms of you know it's nothing like a
story like target I think you've wanted
to hit know they want to make ya killer
yeah so you know that's alright like I
said I mean really nitpicking and you
know there's nothing really bad about
it's just you know after the other ones
it's like oh this is okay this is kind
of a more quieter one but no there's
still some interesting stuff and I can't
wait to see the next one and we will see
you